coupable de champion s'est demandé quels
étaient vos champions avoue qu'avant
alors moi j'avais pensé à des réponses
de deux champions vous allez voir que
voilà en fonction des âges on n'est pas
forcément dans les mêmes époques parfois
on est au néolithique l on va commencer
avec vous ça va bien pensé à ça on ne
veut pas pas du tout pas du tout
d'accord alors qu'il est votre champion
l'a écoutée quand on m'a posé la
question ça m'est venu spontanément moi
c'est madiba c'est-à-dire mandela
abbaoui à babré web nobel de la paix un
cadre de l'estoril faudrait dire oui
parce que cet homme il s'est battu
quentin ségrégation en afrique du sud on
le sait il a été le premier président
noir
non mais et c'est après la maîtrise et
yvonne et à témoins la journaliste
la finalisation ci est très classique
voilà évidemment il a été le premier
président noir en afrique du sud en
quatre vingt quatorze s'est bien battu
et quand même rester 27 ans en prison
pierre est fidèle à ses convictions
c'est un homme remarquable qui a oeuvré
pour la paix ce prix nobel évoquant
archi méritée je suis à nos que c'est
votre champion très belle manche à balai
revanche bercy christine kelly mon
champion je suis resté très terre à
terre très sportive a beaucoup donc moi
j'ai choisi tony parker oui parce que
s'il était petit enfin il encore petit
mince frêle
non mais attendez non non ne l'est pas
créer n'est pas petit pour le signer les
petits moi je suis très réputée à
l'équipe
je termine ma phrase
benjamin gille et et non mais
honnêtement quand il a commencé à
manquer de lits non mais parce qu'il
était petit frêle mince personne ne
misait sur leur tout le monde se moquait
de lui lorsqu'il a dit qu'il est jouée
aux etats unis parmi les plus grands du
monde le regarde en se disant mais c'est
pas possible et on passait ses journées
à se [ __ ] de sa gueule si vous verrez
la réception et il a réussi aujourd'hui
il fait partie des top 10 de l'histoire
du basket mot merci beaucoup que les
sénégalais pour ce moment historique
qu'on soit bio bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors m quel est votre champion napoléon
écoutez moi je les choisis
je n'ai choisi dans ma famille c'est un
champion qui est connu dans la famille
puisque c'est mon père il a été champion
universitaire de france d'aviron et il a
une femme certes et gringalets et
agrégats les et voilà il c'est un grand
et un grand résistant et si je pense à
lui aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai c'est que
j'écris actuellement un livre sur lui
parce qu'il a vu une famille alors moi
comme vous dites pas prendre forcément
un sportif j'ai pris mon grand-père a
c'est de mieux en mieux
[Applaudissements]
roland la tribune boulogne et gilles
verdez morini bosc
je voudrais pas faire l'abbé pierre ou
chose comme ça c'est mon grand père mon
père roger parce qu'ils étaient
astrologues et en fait il m'a aidé à
passer l'adolescence à ce que chaque
année il me faisait mon thème et il me
disait mais oui tu vas te marier avec un
beau garçon mais oui tu iras loin des
gros ça va changer peut-être aujourd'hui
qu'on va vous inscrire sur un site de
rencontres n'ont pas posé la question à
savoir si éventuellement ce serait une
bonne idée peut-être vous inscrire sur
un site de rencontres voilà donc mon
grand père aura peut-être raison enfin
[Rires]
duvernay j'ai pris gustave mon
arrière-arrière-grand-père et ce soir
c'est touche pas à mon n'ai pas d'enfant
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'étais pris celui qui était qui est mon
idole que j'ai la santé rencontrés cet
été c'est youssou n'dour alors tissavel
extraordinaire newson bolt mais si nous
sommes à marty secteur à une ère un
humaniste un homme engagé pour son pays
le sénégal et pour tous les autres pays
c'est quelqu'un que j'adore donc voilà
pour moi c'est le champion des champions
et ses dégâts l'on pense pour mémoire à
tout à fat aux cons ça glisse bien qui
bat dans ma famille j'ai choisi le
champion bien que l'on martin fourcade a
wheel à bien ses missions pour nous
comment vous faites le mais c'est tout
ce qu'ils font c'est et puis c'est un
sacré école de rigueur tu irais des
dizaines de kilomètres et puis
brusquement être obligés de se recentrer
c'est passionnant voir aussi le bien
plus nombreuses à moi je épices et des
sports qui sont pas assez médiatisé ça
et puis pourquoi j'ai beaucoup d'amis
fois champion du monde alors ça tire
bien non mais non ils ont écouté on m'a
confié l'émission jeu juste aujourd'hui
et demain on va y aller doucement au
piano rien d'y aller
maxime gedi rapidement un champion et
potter un championnat un surnom la
foudre l'éclair usain bolt est miss est
impressionnant par son parcours
rappelez-vous en même pas neuf secondes
et quelques 100 m ont été effectués une
grand champion c'est unique au ritz et
robert badinter minutes de la justice
voilà qu'à un infatigable combattant de
l'antisémitisme
quand même aboli la peine de mort enfin
voila il a il a permis d'abolir la peine
de mort et là c'est un grand mesure sous
le seuil des années le directement
dit justement fait la journée contre
l'abolition bien sûr c'est un homme pour
qui l'existence et la valeur suprême
donc voilà il n'y a pas mieux pour moi
y'a pas mieux
merci que sa carrière est vraiment à
gauche alors qu'on les laisse moi
deviner savez que je suis zidane zidane
et bah ouais et remo il a eu il a vécu
un rêve il a commenté qu'il a commenté
une finale de coupe du monde
ouais c'est quelqu'un 18 non non la
dernière norme leed or je donne donc non
sans zidane mais tout ce qui touche y
réussit il ya une des ligues des
champions en tant que jeu erding ligue
des champions en tant qu'entraîneur
voilà le real de madrid la juventus
c'est un grand champion il nous a donné
la première coupe du monde en 98 voilà
mon isu voilà j'aime bien mon réseau on
t'embrasse merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]